il est 22 heures lorsqu'une première
fusillade éclate aux mines night bars à
chicha danao ville d'environ 90 mille
habitants à proximité de francfort selon
les médias locaux au moins trois
personnes sont tuées sur ce premier site
une dizaine de coups de feu ont été
entendus par des témoins le ou les
auteurs auraient pris la fuite
direction le quartier de gstaad il
seconde fusillade éclate devant l'aréna
barre bilan au moins cinq morts et cinq
blessés graves
c'était comme dans un film c'est comme
si quelqu'un faisait une blague je
n'arrive toujours pas à réaliser ce qui
s'est passé je pense à tous mes
collègues c'est comme ma famille ils ne
peuvent pas encore réalisé j'espère
qu'il ya de l'espoir que les blessés qui
vivent encore vont reprendre des forces
le mobile de ces attaques n'est pas
encore connue un suspect a été retrouvé
mort à son domicile selon les forces de
l'ordre ces dernières années plusieurs
attaques jihadistes ont lieu en
allemagne
mais la menace d'un terrorisme de droite
radicale plane aussi sur le pays
notamment depuis le meurtre d'un élu
allemand promis grand membre du parti de
la chancelière angela merkel en juin
dernier